vous le connaissez ou par emi on s'est
parlé par textos interposés ce qui m'a
demandée à servier ce que je veux et
vendu l'accord inouïe sur les animaux
parce qu'il est sur un ami je suis plus
peu importe
oui un animal non je sais pas comment je
suis pété noire j'aurais pas qu'ils
changent de rythme alors donc il a il a
dit que lui aussi vous aussi vous aviez
été copiés oui laurent donc voilà dit
que donc tout le monde voilà et est
copié mot là ils n'ont pas pris les bons
extrait parce que série il est vous le
savez moi quand j'ai vu françois damiens
parfois faire des copier coller de mes
caméras cachées je m'en suis pas
offusqué j'aurais aimé qu'au détour
d'une interview parfois il me suit au
moins une fois mais comme je suis très
très fan de françois damiens moi j'ai
acheté ces dvd et je trouve qu'il a un
talent fou ouais j'ai pas fait j'ai pas
fait de procès je mens je m'en fous mais
en fait les irrite les même si dit
qu'ils tournent un peu on va pas se
mentir c'est en écho pièce que dire
qu'on est bon donc c'est plutôt flatteur
et rémy dit qu'il ya des sketches à lui
auraient été copiés par d'autres cas
voilà qui sont nés gamme sur 100 et puis
sur souvent dans l'inconscient et reste
un truc et quand tu écris tu crois que
c'est une bonne vanne et puis c'est une
vanne que tu à pompe et voilà c'est bon
ça arrive ça va être avec moi je suis
commence à gratter un film comme ça et
au bout de cinq pas que je suis à vinça
directeur du mec dans le nord la wii
quelques voulait réagir oui j'aurais le
problème c'est que rémi gaillard a été
accusée donc par un humoriste étrangers
plage de copies de plagiat ouais là il
se met à insulter la presse il se met à
trouver des vidéos de baffie en fait je
trouve qu'il est un peu à cran
il faudrait qu'ils se calment qui
reprenne ses esprits parce que si c'est
moi je vous dis mon point de vue si que
sexy comme ça peut-être que ces livres
et vous voyez trois mois mais non